[Music]
so we'll talk about public datasets
today so my name is Shane glass I'm the
program manager for the Google cloud
public dataset program I've got a couple
of themed colleagues that will be
joining me here later on stage in a
minute but so we're gonna talk about
accessing and analyzing large-scale
public datasets in Google Cloud so
here's today's speakers you can see the
one on the left that's obviously the one
with the great jokes that's me
and then the other two gentlemen joining
me is Felipe Hoffa one of our developer
advocates and dr. ed Kearns the chief
data officer for the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration so I want
to start with a quote this is from from
faith daily from last year at next I
would have loved to recorder this year
but I didn't know what a keynote was
going to be so I'm using last year's
quote but it says we need to scale what
we need is a is more scalable and
effective way to democratize data for
data scientists and I love this quote
because it is it is such a dead-on
description of what our program is
looking to do the the Google cloud
public data set program and that's
working with public data set providers
like NOAA and like NIH with the
partnership that was announced earlier
this week to host copies of their high
value high demand data sets on our cloud
to reduce the burden for data scientists
and to make their workflows easier to
help them get to where they need to be
we're talking about eliminating barriers
to entry for things like basic
utilization of data and being able to
open up these really really valuable
datasets to data set to users who come
from a non-traditional partners so from
non-traditional backgrounds excuse me so
how do we do that well we we load them
into some of our tools we curate the
datasets and we can dive in us a little
later but it's about making data
available to everybody you don't have to
know where to go what to look for or
what you're trying to find before you
have to find it so a little bit about
myself if you were at next last year and
you have an exceptionally good memory
than you know that I was not the one
giving this presentation last year so I
am the the public data sets program
manager I joined Google
in April of this year coming over from
Noah where I manage the big data project
before this and I answer that question
upfront no I do not know when the next
hurricane is going to hit Edie might
well you can ask that later and so my
background is in data analytics and so I
come into this space from a load of
perspective but I come at it with the
understanding of that it can be really
really difficult to access and find open
data when I was working my master's
degree I very distinctly remember that
the biggest frustration I had wasn't
learning Python it wasn't learning R it
wasn't visualizing data that was
actually out of fun it was finding open
datasets to do all these things on and
that was a huge frustration for me and
it's made me really passionate about
open data and so that that's one of the
reasons I wanted to come over and I want
to make these data more democratized for
our users so currently in the program
now we have a little over 90 data set
somewhere between 90 and 100 and you can
see the typical scatter shot right it's
it's not really a session it next if you
don't have a scatter shot of other
people's logos so you'll see these are
primarily government agencies some
states some cities some local but what
you're really seeing here is is a list
of the public data some providers whose
data were hosting and these are on
boarded and maintained by Googlers with
with input and guidance of course from
the subject matter experts that are the
data providers and what this really
means is that it's not just a random
collection of data that someone sticks
in a object store and never looks at
again there's a Googler going in and
discovering finding downloading
extracting transforming curating and
maintaining these data sets and we think
that provides a better user experience
than other public dataset programs
because we were putting the effort in
and the time in and our expertise and
the engineering to bring these datasets
to you and so we we work closely with
these providers to make sure that we
understand what the best practices are
for them and that we can describe the
metadata as properly as possible so what
we'll just go over some like really high
level numbers that sound really
impressive and you guys can decide if
they mean anything but so we've had in
bigquery alone since next of 2017 so
approximately one year ago we have had
more than
80 petabytes queried and I'm seeing here
from from Chad that that numbers
actually higher than it than the last
time I looked which is about a week ago
so that number is probably closer to 90
now actually so 90 petabyte higher than
90 here 95 95 do I hear ninety-five
hundred eight hundred one hundred okay
some way off so so this is what I saw it
from this is a small sample of the data
since I was looking at and I probably
extrapolate this is accurate least I
could have but yeah so a lot right and
so that that's really the answer there
is people are using a lot of public data
but it's it's in bigquery now hang on
because the public data we get doesn't
always come in a CSV or it doesn't come
like preloaded in a bigquery table right
and that's what I talked about earlier
where there are Google errs that are
building pipelines and that are
extracting this data into bigquery
because it's it's an easy sequel server
list implementation that you could come
in and build on top of right away and
one of the really exciting announcements
from this week is the bigquery machine
learning introduction that allows you to
go on and build machine learning
applications on top of your sequel
queries using declarative statements so
we have more than two thousand tables in
bigquery for public datasets with more
than 42 billion rows yes I did count
each of them individually thank you for
asking and more than 5,000 distinct
users per week and this is a number
we're really excited about because you
know if one user is querying 80
petabytes of data that's great but it
doesn't necessarily mean that we're not
as we're not necessarily democratizing
that data for the broader community but
to see that that volume number grow with
the number of users and with the number
to sync projects that's really exciting
for us because what that means is that
we're we're improving the access for
users we're making it easier for users
who may or may not have been data users
in the past to come in and leverage this
data but it's not just jeez it's not
just bigquery we have public data also
in GCS so Google Cloud Storage we've
more than three petabytes of data there
that includes things like radar imagery
so we have weather radar imagery going
back to 1991 all the way until about 15
minutes ago
and then we have satellite imagery as
well from the geostationary
environmental satellite 16 to go 16 to
meteorological satellite that orbits
that the over the same point in the
earth at all times and that's all I know
about satellites but it is a a high
resolution both in space and time for
imagery and it provides us the ability
to to better understand weather patterns
as they're unfolding we have a the
archive of that going back to last year
as well when it became available so it's
a quick overview of Google bigquery for
those who that aren't familiar I
mentioned earlier it's a server list
data warehouse that's built to support
big data analysis
Felipe's got some great demos on on
bigquery coming up but the one thing I'm
gonna hit on is that it you don't have
to worry about developing or managing or
or building the infrastructure it's
already built all you have to do is put
your data in bigquery and write your
sequel statements on top of it and it's
it scales seamlessly and allows you to
share your analysis very easily so
there's a free tier for storage and for
queries that the values are listed up
there but what that means is that you
can go in and you can start using the
program today without incurring costs
assuming you're below these these values
so how can support open data use we have
a few like very general profiles up here
so the first one is businesses I've
talked to several businesses who have
told us that they exist because the
public data is in GCP and what allows
them to do is it allows them to focus on
their idea they don't have to focus on
building data access mechanisms they
don't have to focus on maintaining these
data access mechanisms or storing them
they can focus on building their product
and delivering their product to their
users and they can do so on top of these
public data sets either by joining with
their proprietary data which we think is
a really valuable way to use it or by
building their product on top of the
data to deliver new insights to users
for researchers you can join multiple
public datasets together to do an
analysis and ways never been done before
one of the things that really excites me
is the ability to bring data together
that has previously lived in silos that
like aren't even on the same farm if
we're gonna stick with a silo analogy so
you're you're looking at data that
just never been brought together before
or is has not been brought together in
such an easy-to-use format before that
can be joined together to find some new
insights and then for data providers you
can provide fast and simple access to
your data without having to scale your
on-premise services so your storage
scales to a million users or to one user
for the same effort so without further
introduction Felipe hello can you hear
me thank you
Thank You Shane so I'm Felipe Hoffa and
Shane gave me this time to talk about
issues that matter to me last year I
showed space versus tabs on code but
today I want to speak about a real issue
people are fighting on the internet
about this where do we put our commas
and I'm talking about sequel who knows
sequel here excellent
so sequel is awesome is a language
invented in 1978 we still use it we
still love it and you must have learned
sequel with a query like this select
name from employees where they come from
substrate then you will want to get more
columns there and then you add a third
column and then suddenly things don't
work why because I have this hanging
comma here and this is because language
create or decided that you could not put
a comma there every other modern
language will allow a coma but sequel
will not so now people who are in two
camps some people put their commas at
the end some people could put the commas
at the start who puts their commas at
the end okay who puts their commas at
the start two three four okay that's
super ugly but that's what I do too it's
much more efficient for me if I put my
comments at the start given the language
limitation so now the question is can I
use data to prove to everyone else that
this is what you should do so
trailing commas lead-in commas we are
Google we use we have Google Cloud
we have bigquery we have data that
everyone can see share and analyze
I will look at github just to count the
number of events that we have and github
last year gave me three seconds five
four three hundred million events and I
can go further I can count for example
the number of these thing users and I
can look at where are they coming from
what are the most important countries
here and the most most developers come
from nool country than the US then China
India but that's not a fair ranking I
should be do it per capita so who has
more programmers per capita turns out
it's Iceland Sweden Norway cold
countries is it true that it's cold
countries or or not I also had Noah date
I have weather data so if I take on one
hand my programmers per capita I take
the average weather of each country I
can get to a chart like this that shows
that yeah there is a correlation people
in cold countries have a high
concentration of programmers warmer
countries lower concentration of
programmers except Singapore there
because they have very good ID so
programmers prefer to say inside a real
query so let's go back to this issue
let's use also we have github code
inside bigquery and I'm able to analyze
our people using more commas at the end
or at the beginning this is my query and
the results show that way more people
use a comma at the end but this is not
really what I want to know I don't want
to know what's more popular I want to
know what projects are more successful
and how do you measure success a larger
number of stars starts last year the
number of contributors activity so I can
write a bigger query that looks for all
of these and turns out that these are my
results and projects that allow people
to use lead in comas or doubler
successful of the other projects so yes
we win
F and yes could be query connects to all
these tools and you will be able to use
open data to share and even if these
fights do not stop at least you can
embrace that I won't go through them I
want to show you a couple more features
that are new and I'm super excited about
them have you heard about data studio
yes
so with that as to you now I'm able to
take my bigquery analysis and I can
create interactive visualizations I
recently created this one for Stack
Overflow and I can embed my
visualizations in the middle of my blog
post I can make them interactive these
are the trends in stock overflow like
let's look for example angularjs one of
the top tax on this side angularjs is
going up or down down wise angularjs
going down because they replace it with
a new tag that is angular so whatever
technology you are interested in people
can come play here and use public data
on the satellite side this is outside
bigquery my friend Lac with a great
friend of everyone that knows about
machine learning and weather forecasting
he created this great sample looking at
hurricanes we have in bigquery a list of
all the kubrick ends you can see what's
happening so we don't know when it's the
next one but we know all the previous
ones you can use to get their data and
then you can find the files the
satellite images the correspond to those
Hugh reckons that keeps cold and you
finally can produce get individual
images create animations and look at
what is happening all around the world
with just some few lines of code that's
the power of having the public data sets
available and the last thing I want to
show for everyone there is a fan of
bigquery and have seen my Wikipedia demo
for example in this demo I'm going to
process 377 gigabytes of data
I'm going through billions of page views
that wikipedia has cinema and when I run
this query I just want the sum of use
for Google this query is processing 377
gigabytes which is an awesome demo but
since you have one free terabyte every
month you would be able only to run
three of these queries so good as a demo
but not so good for public data and the
best news we got for me this yesterday
is that now we can cluster tables we can
runs we can set data together so now
when I run my query over this new table
same query same amount of data same we
think it will process 375 egg whites
instead it's only went over 80 gigabytes
of data so what where we are taking our
public data sets program now we are
going to cluster all tables and make it
way more effective yes G delt I'm
looking at you Kelly we are going to
make these tables all time partition and
cluster by the call of people our query
and with that let me welcome Shane back
to take it over thank you thanks Felipe
in the interest of full disclosure I
didn't start using leading commas until
I saw Felipe slides and realized how
wrong I was
now I did see in Felipe's demo however
that there are people who are using both
leading and trailing commas and those
people just want to watch the world burn
I I'm terrified of you you're monsters
okay so next up we have ed Kearns here
from NOAA Edie is NOAA's chief data
officer he's the first chief data
officer of NOAA and he's been a great
collaborator of the public dataset
program and I look forward to hearing
from him
thank you very much
so you wonder why there's a government
employee up here talking at Google but
we have this partnership that I'm gonna
describe and you've seen the results of
this partnership it's very very powerful
so you know one of the things I do as
NOAA's chief data officer I'm trying to
find the the maximum exploitation of the
taxpayers dollar that you've paid for
these expensive satellites you fix but
you've paid for a lot of collection
systems that bring data from the
environment into NOAA and we use that
for our mission okay
but we also realized as a secondary use
for this data all right so we're using
it for managing fisheries we're using it
for weather forecasts we're using it for
for managing our ecosystems along the
coastlines but we understand that you as
maybe a small business owner can also
use this public open data for other
purposes and we understand this value
there and we want to maximize that value
and so you know so like I said we have
our mission but the secondary secondary
uses you know how can we maximize this
this started about four years ago we
realized well we don't have the
resources within the federal government
to fully exploit the data but hey you
know Google does and can we find a way
that we can work together in a
partnership to actually bring that value
for it and democratize the data as Jayne
was mentioning so let me first explain
how big NOAA is so we're a fairly big
organization we have a very wide scope
of what we do for the American public we
have about 12,000 people of this 12,000
people we've got 7,000 scientists all
right and all those scientists work with
data every day they they are
oceanographers like I am their
meteorologist their biologist their
fisheries experts every single one of
them is it is also a data scientist in
in their in their realm of expertise
because data is the heart blood of our
organization nothing happens in NOAA
none of these products get off of the
American people without data flowing
through them I also have an enormous
challenge if I want to share this data
all right so at any given day
we've got about 200 petabytes of data
residing across NOAA's fed
systems these are not in the cloud
largely okay these are within behind
firewalls on federal systems across the
United States
we've got about 70,000 data sets okay so
that's an enormous number to try to try
to understand if you if you go out just
go out on the on the regular internet
and you try to find all these data sets
and they are almost probably 95% of
these are publicly available today in an
open fashion if you can find where they
are okay and so that that's a challenge
we've got twelve hundred registered web
domains so you got two hundred and forty
thousand individual websites that are
out there that all have data so it's
very hard for you all to find and
consume the data that we have but we try
to find different ways of doing this so
and we're trying to embrace the cloud
trying to bring new technologies and
last year we did use the cloud in order
to try to make sure everybody that
needed hurricane data hurricane forecast
data before a hurricane or Burma hit
Florida that they had access to it and
last year yes indeed we're getting a
billion hits a day and because we're
using cloud technologies in front of our
federal services we're able to do that
so a great great a great success story
but we are also like usually the number
two or number three website in all of
the United States government because so
many people need our data every day so
with in order to use this there's two
challenges one is technical how do you
get the data and the example that Felipe
just showed that lack had put together
it really shows how how working with
Google has simplified this because
before that if you wanted to work with
our satellite data and work with our
hurricane data you had to download all
these different things back to your to
your to your own local computer say or
wherever it might be and then try to do
things with it what this example showed
is you can do everything in place so
some of our data sets our climate models
are about a petabyte in size it's really
hard even to move that data within our
own organization much less get it out to
you so you can use it so these are these
are some of the technical challenges but
the bigger challenge that we're trying
to to to fix is the understanding to try
to figure out what these data mean and
how to convey that understanding to you
I've got 7,000 scientists that know
exactly what this data mean but how do
they interact with you to convey the
meaning because like I said we've got
the data parked out there already we've
had the data parked out there for many
years
and it's not getting picked up and used
in the kind of way that it is being used
when we're seeing we put it on the
Google platform and that's what we're
trying to learn more about so what we
did four years ago is we signed what's
called a cooperative research and
development agreement or crater as it's
a it's a government term but it's a way
of actually having an experiment going
on with industry where there's that
there's no money exchanged but where we
have agreed to work on a common problem
and we've been doing this for four years
with Google right now so this comes with
no cost to the taxpayer the trick here
is that these data are open data they
remain open Google is not selling the
data they're selling services around the
data so they can recoup their investment
but they are hosting the taxpayers data
from there for free and so we understand
how how that can scale how we and you
just saw examples of this of how the
clouds can scale on the open data can
scale the availability can scale but
they really get over the hurdle we're
focused on the expertise because I can
park a lot of this complicated data out
there and you still won't know exactly
how to use it right so we have to we
have to solve this so and so you heard
about some of the examples and some of
the successes already the the sweet spot
that we found instead of just parking
the data out there if we're loading the
data into the tools that people are
already using and bigquery is a perfect
example of this by loading NOAA's
weather data into bigquery people can
come and use that data join on that data
consume that data they don't have to
break down a complicated scientific data
format they don't have to try to
understand what all these mean they
understand hey as temperatures
precipitation is cloudiness it's wind
they understand what it is it's already
loaded into the tool they're using they
can immediately consume it and use it
that's a very exciting paradigm and
we're trying to see how we leverage this
so we're comparing you know it's sort of
an a/b test how's this working on Google
versus how it's working from our own
federal servers and we're seeing it at
least 10 times probably between ten and
a hundred times more consumption of
these weather data coming out of
bigquery than we're seeing from our own
internal services right
and this came when we first did when we
first started this you know about a year
ago now I guess when I first got this
off the ground one of the interesting
things is we didn't advertise it no it
didn't advertise availability of these
weather data in bigquery yet Google did
not advertise it yet they were still
thinking about how they're gonna proceed
right but while we're talking about what
we're gonna do next
users of bigquery came in and found the
data anyways and they started to consume
it it required no advertising we didn't
have to put out any press release that
these data were available people were
just able to find and use it and that's
that's a great story
being able to combine data sets and the
example that Philippe showed that with
the Hurricanes that lack put together is
again just a great example of bringing
multiple data sets together that
otherwise may be hard to do but when
they're all in the same place on the
same cloud it becomes really trivial and
so where are we going with this - all
right so we're trying to find those
increase levels of usage for our data
we're trying to make sure you the data
consumer can get the data more quickly
we have our archive system we have 30
petabytes in our archive it is still a
tape based archive with the archive is
primarily preservation but we make all
those data open it is very hard to get
30 petabytes out of a tape archive as
you all know right however this data are
sitting on the cloud it's it's fairly
trivial and so we're looking at ways
that we can continue to raise that level
of service and and do so in a way that
the taxpayer is not burdened so we're
trying to leverage that value that's in
the data the value to - Google's users
Google's customers trying to leverage
that value to enable this this new way
of providing access to federal data and
so we've been doing this for four years
or a little over three years will be
four years when we're done but we're
really trying to say how can we do this
sustainably how can so we're doing this
experimental e right now we're excited
about the results but you know how do we
how do we take this to the next level
and I really need to hear from you all
okay the federal government needs to
hear is this something that you like do
you like to get NOAA's federal data on
the Google cloud if you find this
valuable we need to
about it we need to be able to as we're
going to our next level of discussions
with Google about how can this work how
can this partnership work sustainably
going on for many years into the future
because Noah's bringing the expertise to
the table all right so that that's what
we're not just bringing the day we're
bringing the expertise and Google's
bringing their infrastructure how do we
maintain that business relationship
we've found it you know and Google's fun
very I found it very valuable valuable
to be able to have those discussions
with no experts to to literally do the
deep dive on ocean data right actually
have those one-on-one discussions and be
able to turn that around and figure out
how do those products fit into the
Google tools and meet the the demands of
their users so we're looking for that
right now there's also a federal data
strategy effort that has just begun as
well and if you go to strategy data.gov
we're in an open public comment period
right now where the federal government
is asking that the the data users across
the country what do you want to see with
federal data do you like things like
this kind of partnership with industry
that allow federal data to be available
on the cloud what would you rather pick
it up from you know a federal service
these are real questions that we're
dealing with right now the timing is
fantastic but honestly this is a time
that we need to hear your voice if you
go to bigquery and you've been
experimenting with these public data
sets if this resonates with you there's
a time right now to to be able to speak
up and be heard and have this kind of
partnership this cloud-based data access
baked into how the federal data strategy
is going to be rolling into the future
and the timing is everything in life
right and so this crater came along at
the perfect time the results have come
along again just just in the nick of
time so that these things can be
integrated into the wider strategy and
yeah please please I welcome if you if
you want to drop me an email at this
this email address or you want to go
enter in your comments and at strategies
data gov I encourage you to do so and
welcome your feedback and I think I'm
turning it back over to Shana
yeah thanks ed and you know I think Edie
touched on something big is and there's
an example of it here on this slide so
in case you haven't heard enough about
laxed mo we got a little bit more here
for you but I think that one of the
things this I think this is a true kind
of big data application right and big
data is one of those buzz words that
it's used to mean everything and as a
result it really means nothing because
it's just you so broad that it doesn't
really have a meaning these days but I
think this is really a big data
application now data is the new oil
right we all heard that I this is not an
original thought this change has had but
I've I've kind of thought about this
phrase a lot I've kind of gone back and
forth on it and I think that my opinion
on that phrase is sort of right data is
sort of the new oil and I think that the
analogy ISM is it's imperfect but I
think it has some value in that data in
its rawest form has value right so
having raw oil just like having raw data
yes that has some value but being able
to process that data to to convert it
into insight into information just like
being able to process oil into gasoline
into plastics that is really where the
valuable application of this product is
and that's what we're trying to unlock
for our users so what you see on the
left is a sample the bigquery table that
lack used for his demonstration on
visualizing the imagery from Hurricane
Maria and so what that is is it's called
IB tracks there's a very long acronym
there but it's essentially the
international community coming together
and saying we agree that at this place
in time this hurricane was at this place
it is a shockingly difficult thing to
come to agreement on but what we found
is that that doesn't always line ah it's
not always associated with the satellite
imagery to see on the right there and
what we found was that those are in such
different places there in such disparate
locations that they're very rarely
combined moreover while the data on the
left are in CSV are available in CSV the
data on their right are in netcdf for is
anybody familiar with a net CDF for file
format that is not employed by the
federal government
yeah so we have outlay a handful of
people which is which is a handful of
warp it yeah a handful of people it's
just a handful more than I expected
so netcdf is is great for the scientific
community because it does press this
very well and it does a lot of other
things very well but it's not but it's
very very specific to the scientific
community the general data science
community the data scientists out there
as opposed to the environmental
scientists out there are used to using
this so that that's a barrier to entry
you have to go out you have to find
these data you have to find the Python
library for it you have to find out how
to use the Python library for it you'd
find out where to find out how to use
the Python library for it
you have to go back you have to write
your Python for it you have to go eat
dinner because at this point it's
already been all day and then maybe you
could get an analysis and let's work
with federal government but what we can
do here is we can lower that barrier to
entry by putting the data from IP tracks
in bigquery it's now a sequel query away
and we can sub sample by in this case by
hurricane name and we can take that very
easily on the right and we can associate
that with the same center points from
the debt from the satellite imagery that
has the hurricane and now you can go
from data insights faster you can go
from oil to gasoline faster you can get
the value out of your data as soon as
you can as opposed to having to wait and
go through this process we've worked
very hard to eliminate all those
barriers to entry now this slide was
made before the announcement was made
however bigquery launched other geophys
capability or visualization capability
this week and that takes us even further
so we've talked a lot about what we've
done in the past right you've heard a
lot of our metrics in the past you've
heard ed talk about the great
collaboration we've had so far and and
you've heard Philippe talk about some of
the things that can be done with the
datasets we already have and we've
talked a little bit about what we we
kind of want to do right like when we
talked about how we're working with NOAA
right now to figure out what's a
sustainable long term partnership beyond
the end of our agreement next year and
so let's talk a little bit about what
we're going to do so this is a look at
our mission and vision statement for the
program going into next year so our
mission is to maximize the availability
and
ability of flagship public datasets in
Google Cloud we're looking at things
like large large scale data sets that
are putting such a burden on our
providers that they have to limit the
access available to them now in order to
protect their systems from being from
being brought down and overwhelmed and
our vision here is to enable the
development and to leverage
collaborations with key public data set
providers like Noah built around high
impact verticals and so the goal here is
to to take these weather data sets and
not just make them available to the
meteorologists of the world but to make
them available to the entire community
for use and let's see what cool stuff
comes out of it let's see what people
are able to learn let's see what people
are to build for themselves going
forward
so looking at the way ahead we're really
really excited about the launch of
bigquery I'm a little aus you to build
regression models cluster analyses among
other things on top of your data sets
and we think that this helps you create
the only machine learning ready public
data set program available today all you
have to do to to use machine learning on
top of bigquery public data sets today
is go write sequel you don't have to yes
suits cleaner data and unfortunately no
what I I know very few people who like
to clean data but you don't have to find
it you don't to discover it you don't
have to move it you don't have to learn
sensor flow to develop great but you
want to learn tensor flow you can just
write your analysis and you can just get
started the bigquery geo visualization
capability we're really excited about
that in combination with the second
point in the slide which is utility
datasets so what we're focused on going
forward is enabling our partners like
our note like NOAA to onboard the
datasets into our program now does that
mean that Google is never gonna onboard
and curate datasets again no what it
means is that we're gonna continue our
focus on datasets that are more broadly
used across all domains so we have a
group of data sets that we call the
utility data sets they're just things
that we generally find useful for all
users or for large swaths of users right
regarde
of what their their interests are one of
these data sets that's available today
is zip code area so it gives you your
five digit zip code the town associated
with it a few other metrics what we've
added to it recently is the polygon
associated with that zip code area from
the Census Bureau's website so you could
take today and you could visualize it by
zip code your data and take it out to
the bigquery geovisualization capability
and you could visualize your data today
we're hoping to have that that a
demonstration of that and a walkthrough
query for that launched very soon but
that capability is available today as
was announced earlier and so our focus
is gonna be on providing these datasets
that we just generally hear across the
community that people need and allow our
partners and their expertise to scale
out on our platform to reduce that
burden for them so I'm really proud to
announce that in support of this we are
making a five petabytes commitment to
big to public datasets in bigquery my
personal take is that this is this is an
unmatched commitment in the community
right now we are making five petabytes
of bigquery storage available to host
public datasets going forward but and
that's great right and that's that's a
ton of structured data but what good
does it do to store data if to extract
and store data if it's going to be gone
tomorrow right and we hear this concern
a lot with our public dataset providers
that we collaborate with why should I
invest my effort my team's effort into
uploading the data if it's gonna be gone
tomorrow
and because of that we're really proud
to announce that in addition to this
five petabyte commitment we are making
this commitment for five years so this
five petabytes will be available each
year for the next five years to host
public datasets in Google bigquery we're
really excited about this and I think
this is going to enable us to do some
really great things in collaboration
with our partners so obviously when it
started today because Filipe ed and I
have gotten you so excited about
Google's public dataset program I did
not see in the isoing that's good
so if you want to use public datasets I
encourage you to go to these sites right
here that's cloud.google.com slash
bigquery slash public data or
cloud.google.com slash public - datasets
on here you'll find some descriptions
and some overviews some of the datasets
we have as well as some connections out
to sample queries if they're good
they're written by me if not the written
by Felipe that's obviously the way that
that would work and so you can connect
out and I think that's a really great
way to just kind of get started
immediately you don't have to know
everything about the dataset but you can
get an idea for what the structure the
data are and for how to use them and
then kind of build from there so you
don't have to build from scratch
do you have public data I want to be
friends with you if you have public data
you can get started today you can go to
bigquery or you can go to Google Cloud
storage and leverage the free tier of
storage that we meant we talked about
earlier today so if you're under 10
gigabytes for 10 gigabytes a month for
bigquery you can go in today you can
store that and you can make it public
and you could share with anybody and
because of the way bigquery bills it's
the it's the person running the query
that is build fat so you aren't billed
for that same thing with Google Cloud
storage it just obviously would note
there that if your before you share with
other people unless you want to pay the
cost I would put it on a request or
pay's mechanism for that so I think I'm
safe on that one okay but so maybe
you're over the free tier of storage
maybe you have a ton of public data and
that's even better I want to be even
better friends with you feel free to
reach out to us at GCP - public - data
at Google com that goes to myself that
goes to a couple of other of our team
members as well and we'd love to get
started working with you on hosting
public data so thank you so much
everybody for coming out let's have a
round of applause for Philippe and for
Edie and thank you very much
[Music]